joue pour le plaisir d'être entrepreneur
et d'innover de plaire à maquereau ça je
m'en bats les couilles
aujourd'hui les amis on va créer une
start up et ouvrir un réseau social
et crois moi on y arrivera on atteindra
1 aurait volé touchera du bout des
doigts à l'espace ok on y va nouvelle
partie pour commencer l'entraînement le
centre p ci dessous bats les couilles je
suis un requin dans le business à mais
vous avez reçu un nouvel email déjà
attendait et là je viens de la start up
arrêter si l'administration m'assassine
avant même que je vais arrêter s'il vous
plaît sans lever cuba alors très haut il
faut faire un prêt à la banque
easy money c'est la banque de booba
apparemment c'est bon montant 40 mille
dollars drogue poster d'intérêt mec
c'est abuser les banques actuellement
quand tu fais un crédit c'est entre 1 et
3%
je suis renseigné mais que ça abusé je
dois leur rendre 40 6700 alléché
endettés ce parti nous sommes dans nos
bureaux au [ __ ] ils sont beaux nuls
sont nulles ce complètement nu attend
sheikh mohammed version animée depuis
stage en bretagne nouvel emprunt la
banque a accepté de prêter de l'argent à
une entreprise qui s'appelle bats les
couilles je respecte ça vraiment
objectif première chose est dans
l'onglet financé prenez un préau qu'est
engagé un directeur des ventes pour
générer des contrats pas ok alors
employé recrutement chef des ventes
ok on va chercher un chef des ventes
c'est parti un nouveau candidat a été
trouvé au [ __ ] 90% étaient nulles
cellule dégage tu peux être celle des
ventes à monoprix mais clairement pas à
bas les couilles compagnie 88% en plus
avoir un prénom merde il est
complètement nul c'est incroyable assez
facile les blagues sur les prés noah
pour la meilleure celle 1 144 % elle
coûte un max de thune butin ok je
n'embauche pas y perdons pas de temps on
veut la meilleure des meilleures faut
qu'on crée un produit qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais qu un service d'hébergement de
vidéos c'est pas comme s'ils avaient la
concurrence en plus on peut le faire on
va s'appeler ton tube mais je veux
inspirer ses fous j'suis visionnaire tu
verras page de destination développement
qu'est ce qu'il faut comme moi pages
trois pages comment pas ok donc il me
faut un développeur il faut peut-être
qu'on met des ménages et un peu ce
truc-là pc écrans chaise clavier/souris
bureau pour 3000 $ enfin un truc qui
coûte pas cher ok on en met un et
ensuite on en met un deuxième parce
qu'on va avoir un petit développeur qui
va sera mené on va aller coller parce
qu'on veut qu'ils entendent bien alors
candidat candidat elle est efficace et
pas chère et la maaf 7,9 on l'apprend
j'ai pris deux mof où sont les eaux midi
alors statistiques voilà donc là on peut
on peut la faire rechercher des modules
qui vous nous permettre de créer notre
logiciel
on va prendre c'est quoi qui fait comme
modules composant 8 sél à 1000 dollars
il en a pour deux heures ça va il va
aller vite et ensuite on mettra un
composant mc cain moquer et ensuite
c'était un composants modules
d'interface et a bien bossé pas l'autre
putelat apte à les employer ces choqué
c'est moi
ça sent les doigts du cul on va pouvoir
du cem annoncé youtube
la nouvelle plateforme qui hébergera les
plus grandes stars du net de demain mais
demain demande hull pour quidditch prix
fixe et 1600 $ urgence moyenne huit
heures production j'accepte mon véhicule
volé l'argent j'accepte tout que j'en
parle un développeur h plein
développement attendent des engagements
flammes et mon entreprise est cool on va
attendre non j'attends pas vas-y est-ce
qu'on peut livrer le contrat on empoche
plus de 600 $ a été fait en deux 2 allée
chercher un autre contrat
donc pour résumer là je passe mon temps
à trouver des contrats c'est les
entreprises qui m'achètent des
composants eux ils créent les composants
voilà c'est tout ce qui se passe par
exemple la bac n il lui en faut du coup
je clique sur cet esclave cette ombre et
par vaux et je lance la création du back
end le problème fait pour tubes sais
qu'il faut que je trouve un module
d'interface et j'ai pas ça n'existe pas
trois modules allez vas-y c'est quoi les
modules il faut des composants yves asie
je te les faits
je ne crois pas mais développeurs sont
incompétents je vous expliquer pourquoi
très rapidement en gros ils peuvent
produire des modules tous ces modules à
je m'en bats les steaks m'engage à 100%
a par exemple j'ai une commande
il me faut ça un composant de wire frame
ok ils peuvent pas le faire
voilà je peux pas je peux pas le crier
puisqu'il ce n'est pas dans leurs
compétences et pour ton tube le truc
module d'interface pareil ce n'est pas
dans leurs compétences je fais comment
moi oh [ __ ] 1980 dollar parce que
c'est une urgence critique pour
seulement deux modules
j'ai bien fait d'être entrepreneur en
plus j'ai déjà produits ce qui lui faut
pas ce que je fais ça en avance bîmes a
laissé pays on n'en parle plus à l'est
ok on atteint tiers 3 au niveau 5
on pourra regretter des mecs plus
compétents regarder et l'argent au monde
c'est fou on va pour atteindre niveau 5
et avoir un manager est tous là est la
silicon valley à côté c'est du pain
d'épicés il en retard là mais il arrive
à 9h30 et en retard là comment je fais
pour le démolir
regardez ces horaires ses marques et la
peur 17 heures moi je me sentais mes
premiers jeux pour ceux qui commençaient
à 7h j'avoue pardon excusez moi
avant de tenir la baie saint paul
utilité de mal at large des vieilles
gens prennent d'autres sans pitié ouais
je vais faire ça j'en ai absolument rien
à [ __ ] à tort c'est abusé lui c'est
vraiment un [ __ ] il est en train de
faire le composant base de données
regarde la barre où elle en est mon gars
y rester une ligne de code à faire même
pas à caractériser ces bons s'était créé
le mec qui part avant de finir il met en
retard dans la livraison de [ __ ] mais
quelle espèce de petit ton cul alors lui
il va dégager ça fait deux semaines que
entreprises existent ok on est à 25
mille dollars
on survit un vraiment survie urgence
critique 4100 dollar rail esclaves
travail est quand même déchire mais
qu'ils ont fait sans clavier ça grands
contrats allez donnez vous la [ __ ]
qu'il est non mais c'est pas possible il
a appris à côté on économiserait ou quoi
lui mais c'est d'aller je livre à boules
la thune ou quoi trois heures de retard
c'est 900 $ de moins sur 4600 alors là
mon pote tu sais quoi
on va faire employer un mini un manager
[ __ ] je peux prendre un manager le
manager dirige tous types d'employés les
managers de nos employés un bonus de
vitesse mais voilà c'est ça qui nous
faut pour les pourrait booster un peu
mon manager j'espère que ça david
douillet et ouais j'ai sorti le blast
d'un mec très vieux c'est pas mal toi
sarah robbins je t'aime bien encore une
femme très bien elle n'arrive plus à
bosser du tout rires ça va donner quoi
vous avez reçu un email
neil wéber j'ai de mauvaises nouvelles
bonjour j'ai été vraiment très heureux
travailler ici à bas les couilles
malheureusement j'ai récemment senti que
l'emprise mes objectifs sont très
différents l'un de l'autre je
démissionne de mon poste de chef des
ventes
bonne continuation neil web est battu
quoi mumbai qu il tombe le toit sont
joués de virer j'aurais pas à payer des
indemnités chômage à assya j'ai une
mauvaise nouvelle
pendant [ __ ] bonjour j'ai été vraiment
très heureux de travailler laisse moi
deviner malheureusement j'ai récemment
vu que les objectifs de l'entreprise et
les miens étaient différents bla bla
j'ai récemment ressenti que l'entreprise
et mes objectifs sont très différents
l'un de l'autre
on va travailler le bois un peu parce
que je te jure que t'as pas fait une
école de dave c'est impossible et
supprimer ça dégage
oh lala com elle efficace [ __ ] j'ai
trop bien fait de la prendre tout le
monde créé ces petits composants [ __ ]
mais qu'on commence à être un vrai
patron c'est beau urgence critique 5200
tralala je vais triche puis station vous
avez atteint un niveau 4 nouveaux chefs
d'employés chef développeurs h f
développeur s'occupe de fusionner les
composants en modules on va pouvoir
créer notre réseau social mais avant il
faut qu'on amasse un maximum de tune
sinon la clé ira sous la porte pour
écouter je suis un bon patron joie que
cet employé fatigué il en a marre de
coder qu'est ce que je fais je l'envoie
en vacances nouveau contrat quatre co
prince harry
bonjour mr en vacances juste un peu plus
tard ça va
hop là si l'ivresse fn n'en parlons plus
bon maintenant écoute tu as bien
travaillé tu peux aller en vacances
envole toi comme un oiseau
mexes et l'on d'évoluer sa mère feront
pas être caissier à mon dieu un contrat
urgence critique tête 1200 watts et bien
je voulais être caissier à 2 minutes
prime soit 1200 dollars tellement bien
qu'en vacances elle est partie oui moi
ou quoi elle fait coiffer un tour du
monde c'est quoi ce délire l'aéro alors
tes vacances c'était bien tu as la forme
maintenant je parie un fatigue 5,6 pour
cent mais tu reviens de l'acoss nouvel
avantage débloquer boissons gratuites
augmenté à cette facture aux employés en
leur offrant un accès gratuit aux
distributeurs et vous payez comme tout
le monde mais que les pièces de 20
centimes toi même tu sais bon mec un
moment faut arrêter les conneries tu
fais le mec je vais en mettre met une
plante ici un distributeur
si je fais faillite c'est 100 % à cause
de ça qu'il nous faut c'est totalement
un chercheur développeurs pour pouvoir
faire des modules et ouvrir notre réseau
social enchérir watts vous allez être en
compétition avec les autres entreprises
pour remporter ce contrat c'est que
c'est du prix désiré par heure en au
shit nom va se mettre à 220 sinon l'aura
pas et on l'a pas eue superstar des mnu
la volée pour 3900 dollars fils de potes
à moi je vends pas mon que je bosse marc
mépris m'en bats les couilles urgence
critique aux quêtes réfléchissons mais à
28 ans en plus il y en a juste à faire
ça mais que c'est izia faire voire 150
par heure ça c'est bien sanguin
olalalala plus très bien ce très bien se
tenir
c'est hyper grave nous parle
mais qu'on est à 60 2 me de la
trésorerie attendez on va refuser tous
les contrats on va faire notre réseau
social adopte une blague ça c'est hyper
marrant ça va cartonner le principe
c'est les gens post une blague et en
choisit une espace rirm si un problème
dans le concept est en train de
construire les modules pour pouvoir
faire ce qu'il faut c'est chaud mec
adopte une blague implémenter toutes les
fonctionnalités ont été correctement
implémenter cliquer sur un bouton en
dessous pour la mise en ligne frais
d'hébergement 3,75 dollars jour revenu
total 0 $ non mais c'est un sketch
amélioration comment je fais [ __ ]
nombre de modules qu'il faut mais ils
ont fumé
bonjour nous avons actuellement 360 de
l'utilisateur sur adopte une blague ça
cartonne ont gagné dollars par jour yep
[ __ ] les mecs c'est fou ce je suis
addict à sombre adopte une blague a
généré 14 dollars de revenus on peut se
payer un mac do grâce à notre réseau
social c'est incroyable oh là là mais il
va grandir vous allez voir c'est notre
bébé on va le faire mûrir regarder la
courbe revenu 21 dollars 258
d'utilisateurs sur le web et 412 sur
mobile on va l'améliorer
adopte une blague a généré 210 8,21
dollars de revenus objectif atteint
c'est à peu près ce que mark zuckerberg
créateur de facebook gagne chaque
seconde lol
les amis de la fin de cette vidéo et de
cette start up j'espère que ça vous a
plu n'était pas allé mais si c'est le
cas par la start-up la vidéo finalement
avoir une start up c'est un peu une baby
sitter
mais pour des adultes n'hésitez pas
allez vous créer un compte sur adopte
une blague ça me fait vraiment plaisir
ça me permettra de payer ces gens qui
travaillent face à un mur tout c'est
horrible j'aurais pu la mettre face à
face mais non je suis un fdp à l'épreuve
et vous bien un meilleur taux
[Musique]